will President Trump pardon Paul
Manafort will robert muller incite
president Trump's buddies will you drive
a car in ten years these and other
questions will be answered I'm Ben
Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show you know
it's kind of annoying capatch news cycle
meaning that the news cycle is sort of
all over the place it's just it's a
weird news cycle and there's a lot to
talk about in a variety of different
topics we'll get to all of those things
but first let's talk about the coffee
that you need to get yourself going in
the morning sorry to spoil the surprise
but if you are getting a gift from me
this Christmas it would be coffee from
my favorite Coffee Company black rifle
coffee and yes I do indeed give
Christmas gifts to people around the
office and they will be shocked when
they learned that I'm giving them black
rifle coffee they'll be shocked and
surprised and happy and enlightened
because the coffee really is fantastic
black rifle is the only coffee company
out there that gives a portion of their
sales to veterans and first responder
causes black rifle coffee is roasted or
direct guarantees you fresh delicious
coffee with every single order it really
is fantastic stuff and the coffee club
makes things easy just pick your blend
the amount you want black rifle ships
your coffee right to your door every
single month hassle free and they make
giving the gift of great tasting coffee
easy they offer three six twelve month
prepaid and pay-as-you-go subscriptions
available for gifting the best tasting
most energizing and they help better in
first responder coffee causes as well
black rifle coffee is indeed the gift
that keeps on giving check them out at
black rifle coffee comm /ban by the way
they share our priorities keeping
America awesome and as veterans who
founded the company and just go and
check out all their contents online it's
really fun to watch and their coffee
also again happens to be fantastic when
you use black rifle coffee comm slash
Ben you ever see fifty fifteen percent
off your order that's black rifle coffee
comm slash Ben for 15% off black rifle
coffee comm slash ban by the way as I
say I would give black rifle coffee as a
Christmas gift to the people who work
here not only because it's awesome but
also because we have a bunch of it
already stocked to the kitchen so I
really have to do is like open it up and
just hand it off to people at the office
and then I have to pay for the gift
which is like double whammy for me so
that's pretty awesome
alright so today's news all right fine
gif through the news today let's do the
news today all right so the latest news
is with regard to Paul Manafort and
Donald Trump this is my least favorite
news cycle
because the truth is we're not gonna
know anything until the mullah report
actually comes out so everything is
speculation listen to a lot of other
shows and you're gonna get tons of
speculation about Trump and Muller at
mana fort and his Trump gonna be
impeached and his Trump couldn't go to
jail
and if Paul Manafort can be set on fire
by robert muller after being dumped off
the top of the randy's doughnut sign in
downtown los angeles who knows
no one knows right and this is why i
really don't like talking about these
topics so much because i'm an
evidence-based person and that means
that i like to wait for all the evidence
to come out before speculating upon it
however to dings drive me to talk about
this one it's a slow news cycle we got
to talk about something into the fact is
that the news is now replete with
speculation about Muller so let us
debunk some of the speculation a couple
of things right off the top first off
yesterday we reported that there is a
shocked Guardian story from the UK
Guardian talking about Paul Manafort
meeting with Julian Assange the head of
the of WikiLeaks which is a Russian
front group that hacked Hillary
Clinton's emails and John past his
emails and then started releasing them
on mass just before the election and the
allegation has been that President
Trump's campaign was working with
Assange and with WikiLeaks and with the
Russian government in order to skew
election results specifically in order
to prevent Hillary Clinton from being
elected so the Guardian comes out with
his bombshell report and this would be a
big dot to connect right because now you
would have the campaign chairman for
president Trump meeting with Julian
Assange or the head of WikiLeaks in
advance of WikiLeaks releasing these
emails then you'd have Trump out
publicly saying I sure hope that
WikiLeaks will release those emails with
wink wink
and then the emails would come out ooh
collusion well as it turns out not so
fast everyone let's hold that back Paul
Manafort has now denied ever meeting
with Julian Assange now why should we
believe Paul Manafort well maybe we
shouldn't I mean Robert Miller says that
Paul Manafort is a liar and lied to him
we'll get to that in just a second but
mana Ford himself says he is denied ever
meeting Assange following a report he
had met with the WikiLeaks founder at
least three times in previous years on
Tuesday the Guardian reported this
according to cnn.com the mana fort had
secretly met several times with Assange
inside the Ecuadorian Embassy in London
including around the time he was made a
top figure in the Trump campaign
The Guardian citing sources just sources
write not like sources where they are
they in the Ecuadorian embassy are they
in Muller's camp just sources and
whenever is
somebody says I cite my sources let's
just remember that President Trump said
that he had very good sources suggesting
that President Obama was born in Kenya
so his sources don't mean anything
anyway
The Guardian citing sources which is to
say no one said mana Ford had met with
Assange in 2013 2015 spring 2016 mana
fort responded to the Guardians report
he called it totally false and
deliberately libelous and then he kind
of took the lapels on his ostrich jacket
linked with them because that's awesome
Manta Ford said quote I've never met
Julian Assange or anyone connected to
him I've never been contacted by anyone
connected to WikiLeaks either directly
or indirectly
I've never reached out to Assange nor
WikiLeaks on any matter we are
considering all legal options against
the Guardian who proceeded with this
story even after being notified by my
representatives that it was false the
newspaper said it was unclear why manna
fort wanted to see us on what was
discussed it's not just Manta fort
saying that this is false
Isana also says that it's false more
importantly they're a bunch of people
who deal pretty regularly with Julian
Assange and they say it is legitimately
impossible for mana for two a:visited
Assange and for not to be recorded in
the Ecuadorian Embassy logs because this
is one of the problems with the Guardian
story no we're in the embassy logs Paul
Manafort appear Eva Gallinger is an
author who has visited Assange several
times she says quote it is impossible
the mana 420 the Ecuador embassy to see
Assange that was not registered or
videotaped everyone was no exceptions I
was there many times the security were
not friendly to Assange they would have
not done any favours and then she
questioned the sourcing for the article
she said they say documents from say
nein Ecuador's Intelligence Agency
currently being disbanded because of
dubious activities they have fabricated
documents before to serve their agenda
and they are definitely out for Assange
because he published some of their
secret documents The Daily Beast Betsy
Woodruff noted that the Guardian then
went and started stealth editing their
piece self editing means you go and you
edit a piece without actually note
noting the correction sometimes it's
innocuous and sometimes you're actually
changing the material in the piece
without notifying readers so that you're
sort of hiding the boo-boo that you made
before the Guardian weakened some of its
language in the mana fort Assange story
so originally it said it is unclear why
Manta fort wanted to see Assange and
what was discussed they changed it to
read it is unclear why Manta fort would
have wanted to see Assange and what was
discussed right before the last apparent
meeting as opposed to before but the
last meeting
so they're now weakening all the
language men afford was we say is now
threatening a lawsuit against the UK
Guardian so all of the hubbub yesterday
over this bombshell story that mana Ford
had met with massage it turns out that
that may be collapsing in on itself
meanwhile there's a story today about
Jerome Corsi who apparently has a deal
with President Trump Jerome Corsi is the
author and conspiracy theorist who had
written an entire book about why Barack
Obama was born in Kenya he used to write
for WorldNetDaily and he now claims in a
forthcoming book that he has a joint
defense agreement with President Trump
that was provided limited immunity
during his testimony before a special
counsel Robert Mullins grand jury to
discuss a cover story
he claims he crafted for Trump confidant
Roger stone this according to the Daily
Caller course he has been interviewed
six times in the investigation over the
course of more than two months and he
writes in a new book that he entered
into a defense agreement with Trump
after being advised that Trump's lawyer
Jay Sekulow was interested in the
arrangement the defense agreement would
basically involve Corsi under
investigation talking with Trump's team
to inform them of the questions he was
being asked by Muller this of course
would make Muller deeply upset and angry
because you don't want your witnesses
talking to one another and getting their
story straight describing his
interactions with the special counsels
office
Corsi claims he was granted what's known
as limited use immunity for testimony he
gave during his September 21st grand
jury appearance regarding conversations
with Roger stone about an August 31st
2016 memo he wrote about former Clinton
campaign chairman John Podesta Corsi
says she received immunity for testimony
that he and stone developed a cover
story self explained stones now infamous
to August 21st 2016 tweets that would
soon be possessed his time in the barrel
according to core C he and stone hatched
a plan in which course he would write a
memo about the Podesta is to allow stone
to cite it as the basis for his sweet
retro actively so the implication from
stones tweet is that he knew in advance
about WikiLeaks releasing Podesta's
emails and then WikiLeaks released the
emails showing that stone had been
coordinating with WikiLeaks and
presumably if stone was in touch with
the Trump campaign then this would be
the avenue that which Russian collusion
was taking place
Corsi supposedly testa is going to
testify that he and stone came up with
an arrangement where he would sort of
backfill the story instead of it being
that stone was working with wiki
and then he sort of let the cat out of
the bag saying that WikiLeaks was gonna
release stuff on John Podesta now the
story was going to be that your own
course he had come up with a memo and
that was the basis for stones tweet the
revelation of hacker would undercut
stones testimony to the House
Intelligence Committee that opposition
research on the Podesta brothers
business activities was the catalyst for
the tweet Stone vehemently denied course
he's claim about the origin of the memo
to the Daily Caller
on Monday he insisted that he and course
he discussed the Podesta brothers
activities and that his tweet was a
reference to Oppo research that would
come out on the topic and there are a
bunch of Twitter posts on this
particular subject of course he
announced the release of his book on
Monday in an interview he also claims
that prosecutors wanted him to plead
guilty to making false statements
regarding WikiLeaks he rejected the
offer saying he would not plead guilty
to a crime that he did not commit and
again he says that Jay Sekulow Trump's
lawyer suggested a mutual defense
agreement that could be verbal in nature
and did not need to be put in writing
joint defense agreement are common in
criminal proceedings when multiple
witnesses and investigative targets are
dealing with the same prosecutors Trump
has one with Paul Manafort for example
so here's where things start to get
dicey does it look like Paul Manafort
and Jerome Corsi and President Trump are
coming up with a mutual defense
agreement because they are trying to get
their story straight and protect
themselves from the from the special
investigation of Robert Miller or is it
the robert muller is actually being
pradesh estat he has that he's being
predatory that he actually is trying to
peel off these people one by one and hit
them with false allegations and then
force them to turn on each other and
testify about each other falsely and so
you need a mutual defense agreement so
that people can coordinate with each
other from an offense perspective the
latter from a prosecution perspective
the former but does any of this look
particularly good for President Trump
not really when you are coordinating
with other witnesses in a case about you
it looks like you're trying to set up
some sort of cover story course he
writes of one instance in which his
lawyer had contact with Trump's lawyer
he says he wanted his lawyer to warn
Trump we had to assume the special
counselor would have everything all
emails text messages written notes phone
records could be obtained by search
warrants I wanted the president I wanted
the president warned not to give
in-person verbal testimony to Muller
under any circumstances he said
expressing concern the prosecutors
removing sort of perjury trap against
him from misremembering details about a
July 25th 2016
email that he received from Roger stone
and one of those emails supposedly is an
email from 2016 from Corsi to Roger
stone about the WikiLeaks email dumps
NBC News has obtained draft court papers
since of course he by Miller's office in
which course he apparently said that
Roger stone asked him in the summer of
to get in touch with an organization
identified by Corsi as WikiLeaks about
unreleased materials relevant to the
presidential campaign the email from the
two coracii on July 25 2016 from stone
apparently says get to Assange at
equatorial embassy in London and get the
pending WikiLeaks emails of course he
said he declined the request he made
clear to stone that an attempt to
contact WikiLeaks could put them in the
investigators crosshairs according to
the draft court documents Muller's team
said that was a lie instead of turning
down the requests course he in fact
passed it along to a person in London
according to the draft court documents
so we'll have to see how all of this
shakes out course he meanwhile says I
didn't do any of this stuff and the
Muller investigation is simply trying to
push me into making false statements
about President Trump with the threat of
prosecution looming over my head all of
which raises another question is
President Trump going to solve this sort
of Gordian knot by simply cutting it and
pardoning Paul Manafort and this is one
of the pieces of speculation that is out
there today I think this is highly
highly unlikely I will explain why in
just one second first let's talk about
your genetics oh yeah I was a little
disappointed I have to admit Elizabeth
Warren took her genetic test it said
that she was one 120 1024 that Native
American I figured well she's that much
Native American probably sometime a
thousand generations ago somebody in my
family reproduced with a person who
Native American ancestry maybe I am more
Native American and Elizabeth Warren as
it turns out no my line is pure pure
Ashkenazic jewelry 23andme
sent me I mean truth in advertising guys
I'm not hiding anything 23andme finds
that I am 100% Ashkenazi Jewish which
means that a bunch of Lithuanian Jews
married each other for about a million
years and and that's how we ended up
with this but in any case I know that
only because of 23andme which also says
by the way that I have really solid
muscle fiber which I mean honestly I
didn't need a genetic test to tell me
that but it is reassuring and all
so gives me a certain added confidence
on the street now that I know that from
23andme right now through December 25th
the 23andme DNA kits are on sale and
they make a perfect gift you can check
out information about your wellness
muscle composition sleep movement you
can you can check out particular traits
ability to match musical pitch for
example there's genetic aspect to this
mosquito bite frequency like if you're
getting bitten by mosquitoes more often
is it because mosquitoes aren't
attracted to you we can actually find
this out via 23andme now through
December 25th get 30% off any 23andme
kit order your DNA kit at 23andme comm
slash Shapiro that's the number two
three-and me comm / Shapiro again that's
two three and me comm / Shapiro when use
that / up here you get 30% off any
23andme kit find out if you are more
Native American than Elizabeth Warren
because come on it's more in pie it's
impossible for you to be any more
Ashkenazi Jewish than I am so I'm 100%
pure baby so check that out over at
23andme calm right now it's a blast it
really is 123 me calm / Shapiro and you
get 30% off from now until December 25th
okay so manna pop manna forts lawyer is
said to have briefed president Trump's
attorneys according to the Boston Globe
this is a report that came out yesterday
a lawyer for Paul Manafort the
president's one-time campaign chairman
repeatedly briefed president Trump's
lawyers on his clients discussions with
federal investigators after mana Ford
agreed to cooperate with the special
counsel according to one of trumps
lawyers and two other people familiar
with the conversations the arrangement
was highly unusual and inflame tensions
with Muller's office when prosecutors
discovered it after Manta Ford began
cooperating two months ago the people
said some legal specialist speculated it
was a bid by mana Ford for a
presidential pardon and here's where we
get into the dicey territory will
president Trump simply stop this
investigation by pardoning Paul manta
for if Paul Manafort is indeed the key
to this entire thing will President
Trump to say listen you guys have
trumped up all these charges against
Paul mana for you never would have
prosecuted him under any other
circumstances except that he was
involved with my campaign you don't like
me so you went after him for a bunch of
foreign affairs stuff that a bunch of
lobbyists in Washington do all the time
and get away with but you're going after
him now so I'm just gonna pardon him and
then you got nothing then you can't try
to leverage him into making false
statements about me or is he trying to
pardon Manta for in order to obstruct
justice right is he trying to pardon
Paul Manta for in order to prevent the
investigation
from going forward Andy McCarthy has a
long piece about this in national review
today he says Muller's prosecutors are
laying the groundwork to argue that poem
anna fort should not get any credit for
pleading guilty and sparing the public
to need for a second trial because as we
learned yesterday the mauler team now
says that Paul Manafort lied to them
they want to revoke his plea agreement
and that would kick back in all the
possible consequences of severe jail
time in the submission the special
counsel points out the mana fort did not
decide to plead guilty until the last
minute so prosecutors in the court had
to gear up for trial
moreover the prosecutors emphasized the
alleged breach relieves the government
of any duty to support mana forts claim
that has demonstrated acceptance of
responsibility which is a standard
sentencing reduction for defendants who
plead guilty
here's the key for their part Manta Ford
and his lawyers are clearly preparing to
argue that mana fort was honest but that
Muller's rabidly anti-trump prosecutors
did not like what he had to say he would
not implicate the president in
misconduct this would echo at the impa's
ative by judge TS Ellis in Manta force
Virginia trial Muller aggressively
pursued mana for non charges that had
nothing to do with Russia's interference
in the 2016 election in order to squeeze
mana for into singing or even composing
as a witness against the President and
this is where this is where we get into
the pardon issues in just a second I'm
gonna explain to you where the pardon
issue comes in
so as Anna McCarthy continues he says
there is a highly unusual twist here the
possibility the president from could
pardon Manta Ford on the theory the
Justice Justice Department would never
have charged man afford for his
political consulting activities in
Ukraine and lavish income he earned in
fails report from it and the mana fort
was charged as a pressure tactic to help
mala try to make a collusion case
against Trump under circumstances where
there was no evidence of a trump Russia
criminal conspiracy many will bus detect
a play for a pardon in mana forts
alleged breaching of the plea agreement
coupled with his public stance that far
from lying
he has been resisting Muller's
heavy-handed attempt to make him lie
this take on things find support in some
president from sweets such as this one
from August 18th quote I feel very badly
for pop mana fight and his wonderful
family justice to get twelve-year-old
tax case among other things applied
tremendous pressure on him and unlike
Michael Cohen he refused to break make
up stories in order to get a deal such
respect for a brave men so McCarthy says
he doesn't think the Muellers report is
forthcoming but it is possible
that President Trump could simply pardon
mana for risk impeachment in the house
know that he's not going to get
convicted in the Senate and then see
what happens right there and this is the
case that is now being made by both
Jerome Corsi and Roger stone is that
Muller's selective prosecution of mana
fort has resulted in an attempt to make
my and that Muller is now trying to make
your own course you lie and try and make
Roger stone why in order to set up a
chain of events that looks like Roger
stone and Jerome Corsi asked me his
go-betweens for WikiLeaks with the Trump
campaign this is what jerome corsi was
saying yesterday again you gotta say
everything's rome course he says with a
very very large grain of salt as a guy
who wrote an entire book about how
Barack Obama was born in Kenya this is
not a reliable source here is Tucker
Carlson asking him some questions last
night on Fox I've read accounts in the
press I read one in the Washington
Monthly a liberal magazine saying that
you deserve to go to prison because
you've expressed views that they don't
like do you think that your political
views are playing a role in the decision
of the special counsel to charge you
with a felony yes I think and also by
the way they accused me of deleting
emails and I told them to restore they
restored the emails I supposedly deleted
through the time machine
this is a political winch HUD okay so
yeah and this is course ease perspective
it also has Roger stones perspective he
says that Roger stone says the gem
course he's being browbeaten of course
they all have a stake in saying this
because if they're not being browbeaten
then somebody's going to jail probably
here's Roger stone trying to defend your
own course he August 21st I posted a
tweet that said the Podesta's time in
the barrel will come I meant that public
scrutiny of the Podesta's Russian
business interests as I had been briefed
about by Gerry Corsi would be in the
media now Gerry Corsi has been browbeat
into claiming that that was some kind of
a cover story and because I was taking
heat for that tweet but that's not even
logical Laura because my tweet wasn't
controversial until six weeks later when
with Julian Assange published John
Podesta Gmail's
right except that it would make sense
for the tweet to be uncontroversial
until then because you said it
cryptically that it would time dude
there'd be time for John Podesta in the
barrel and then later it was John
Podesta time in the barrel which makes
it seem like he had some inside
information that
all of this is questionable will this
result in mana for being pardon simply
too and this I really doubt that I think
the president Trump would would not do
that I think would be a mistake I think
that he would be impeached automatically
by the new democratic house I think that
they would have a relatively solid basis
for doing so it would look too much like
obstruction for them to avoid doing
anything else and it would put
Republicans in a terrible position now
they either have to say that it's okay
for the president to pardon people who
are being questioned about his campaign
activities in order to avoid scrutiny or
they have to vote against the
president's remaining in office I don't
think that President Trump is going in
this direction lending credence to the
idea he might go in this direction was
the fact that yesterday he was in an
interview with somebody I believe from
the Washington Post and he was asked
about the possibility of pardoning manna
for he went off the record and then the
reporter said can you put any of that on
the record and then they went back off
the record that suggests that Trump is
thinking thoughts that he doesn't
necessarily want people to to know about
again mr. president don't do this let it
go forward if this investigation turns
out to be the Sham that a lot of people
think it is
if this investigation turns out to be as
empty and as and as goal-seeking as it
appears to be in many cases then we will
all be here to defend you against false
charges but if you cut this thing short
it's gonna look like you're guilty and
it's gonna look like you're guilty
because maybe you're guilty so don't do
it
so don't pardon Paul Manafort it would
be a big mistake at this point
president Trump however is busy
fulminating on Twitter about all of this
again I'm not sure how this is helpful
to him he is saying the Miller
witch-hunt is a total disgrace they're
looking at supposedly stolen crooked
Hillary Clinton emails even though they
don't want to look at the DNC server but
have no interest in the emails that
Hillary deleted and acid-washed after
getting a congressional subpoena again
it's true
Hillary should have been prosecuted it
is also true that this does not actually
mean that you are innocent of things
just because somebody else is guilty of
a thing president Trump then retweeted a
and they count called the Trump train
with a graphic of virtually every
Democrat on planet Earth behind bars and
it says now that Russia collusion is a
proven lie when do the trials for
treason begin so all good times over on
president Trump's Twitter account in
just a second I want to get to President
Trump who appears to be fulminating more
often than I think is useful for him
again the economy's
I don't see why were doing this we'll
get to that in just one second first
let's talk about you getting better at
investing you don't know all that much
about investing you want to practice
investing you want to you want to get
more expert with investing well the best
way to do that is by getting Robin Hood
it's an investing app that lets you buy
and sell stocks ETFs options encrypt
those all commission-free
they strive to make Financial Services
work for everyone not just for rich
people it's a non intimidating way for
stock market newcomers to invest for the
first time with true confidence they
have a cost structure that does not
charge per trade instead you trade the
stocks you keep all of your profits
they've easy to understand charge market
data you can place a trade in just four
taps on your smart phone the Robin Hood
web platform also lets you view stock
collections 100 most popular
entertainment social media you can group
them all so you learn by doing
hey just by using the app you're getting
better at trading because it takes
experience to get better at knowing how
the stock market works Robin Hood is
giving listeners a free stock like Apple
Ford or sprint to help build your
portfolio sign up today at Shapiro dot
Robin Hood com
that's Shapiro dot Robin Hood com when I
was much younger when I was back in
college I actually tried to take out an
account and one of these other trading
sites it turned out to be a colossal
fail that will not happen for you when
you use Robin Hood simply because
they're giving you more information than
you'd get from other places and they
make it a lot more user-friendly and a
lot easier doesn't mean you won't lose
money maybe it will but you'll be
learning the entire time go check it out
right now
Shapiro dot Robin Hood calm that's
Shapiro dot Robin Hood calm and you get
a free stock like Apple Ford or sprint
to help build that portfolio
okay so President Trump obviously is is
in a mood I think he is not happy with
with that with the how the midterms went
he shouldn't be
we lost 40 seats Republicans did in the
house they only picked up two seats in
the Senate so it's 53 seat majority for
Republicans in the Senate that is not a
supremely strong majority it's a little
stronger and it was obviously the house
was a complete wipeout in the end it was
a blue wave people who tell you
differently are fibbing to you 2006 to
the blue wave Democrats won in the House
popular vote not the stupid Senate
popular vote which means nothing in the
house popular vote Democrats won in 2006
by 8 points they won in 2018 by 8.1
points so if 2016 was 2006 was wave so
was 2018 President Trump not happy about
that obviously not happy about the media
treatment justifiably obviously unhappy
about all the headlines being leaked
from the Muller
investigation and this is causing him to
do what he does a lot in social media
and publicly which is puff up his chest
and right now would be the time to go
quiet seriously
what President Trump needs to understand
I think that sometimes he gets in
sometimes he doesn't he let's put this
way I think he gets one half of the
equation
president Trump has the capacity to draw
spotlights that is a wonderful capacity
in a politician President Obama could do
it too it's great when you're a
politician who is capable of drawing
spotlights from every angle it means
they can shift topics pretty easily
president Trump likes the attention he's
always liked attention he's a guy who is
on the cover of Playboy magazine back in
the 90s and this is somebody who does
not shun attention but the president
because he has such capacity to draw
attention also has the capacity to
deprive the media of fodder just by
going silent the media would drive
themself nuts every time President Trump
goes out of the country and he travels
around he's busy all the time his
approval ratings fire rise five points
not kidding go back and look at the
record the reason for that is because
the media have nothing to play with
right the president is just going around
doing presidential things he's not
tweeting he doesn't have access to cable
TV he's just going around doing what the
president should be doing every time
president Trump misdirect away from a
topic of importance or gives the media a
topic to focus on that is not good for
him it is a problem for him and a
problem for Republicans well president
Trump because you know bad mood though
is now fulminating and he's doing it a
lot on Twitter again Twitter is sort of
zealot I got a text from somebody today
I'm the left saying do you think
President Trump is going on Twitter
strategically and I was like nope I
think he's bored and I think that's
pretty obvious from his Twitter feed
this morning he retweeted a tweet from a
fake Mike Pence account he retweeted a
bunch from an account called the Trump
train a couple of those tweets are
actual factually they're factually wrong
so he retweeted
he retweeted the Trump train saying
illegals can get up to $4,000 a month
under federal assistance program our
Social Security checks are on average
$1,200 a month retweet if you agree if
you weren't born in the United States
you should receive zero dollars of
assistance that last part is true the
other part is based on Canadian
statistics it's not actually based on
American statistics and then he started
retweeting accounts that were tweeting
out old footage of Hillary Clinton
talking about
Eric Holder and Cory Booker as black
people and we'll get to GM in just a
second but you can tell the President
Trump is bored but and when President
Trump is bored and feeling bad he tends
to sound off about how great he is
because today I'm thing and why so he
did an interview with he did an
interview yesterday in or at least there
was a new book out Tuesday and the
president in this book said that while
he said he feels that quote I blow
Ronald Reagan away hmm it's a statement
it's a statement says the amazing thing
is they have certain people who are
conservative Republicans that if my name
weren't Trump if it were John Smith they
would say I'm the greatest president in
history and I blow Ronald Reagan obey
hey I've said before I think the
President Trump has governed more
conservatively than Ronald Reagan I do I
think that he is governed more
conservatively than Ronald Reagan he
does not have Ronald Reagan's capacity
to win 49 states or to draw the country
together or to be optimistic Reagan was
a lot more than just his policy but on
policy Trump isn't wrong that he's quite
good but that was not the best quote the
best quote from President Trump in these
various interviews I mean this is like
full-on Yogi Berra stuff it's so good so
president Trump in this interview he did
an interview on Tuesday with the
Washington Post and he said a lot of
stuff so he was asked about the declines
on Wall Street and GM's announcement was
laying off 15% of its workforce
President Trump responded by criticizing
the Fed he said he's not worried about a
recession and then he said quote about
the fattie said they're making a mistake
because I have a gut and my gut tells me
more sometimes then anybody else's brain
can ever tell they strong stuff strong
stuff I gotta admit that's that's that
solid stuff I have a gut and my gut
tells me more sometimes than anybody
else's brain can ever tell me well it
depends if you've had like a burrito
lately really if your gut is telling you
more than somebody else's brain could
ever tell you my cumin tells me more
than Albert Einstein spent kardec's
let me tell you something my back is
more intelligent than any number of
experts from the American Enterprise
Institute what's funny about this now I
do have to know I'm making fun a
president Trump over this Barack Obama
was exactly the same way Morocco's eggs
cailli the same way he famously turning
the 2008 campaign said that he was his
best campaign manager his own best
speech writer his own best policy wonk
he was his own best everything
Barack Obama loved him some Barack Obama
I mean Barack Obama like President Trump
trusted trusted his gut mainly because
he got to know his God face to face by
sticking his head up his own ass so
often but President Obama I when you
talk about people who are egotistic
again I'm making fun of President Trump
simply because I think that President
Trump would be better served by simply
receding into the background letting his
policies take the floor and by the way
he's not wrong when he says he'd get
more praise if he acted more
presidential what he's saying in that
first quote about how he's better than
Ronald Reagan well then why don't you
let people I don't know look and enjoy
your policies as opposed to you
fulminating online in any case as I say
when people say that Donald Trump is a
wild departure from the president for
presidential politics let's just
remember he's not the first guy who
loves him some some president here's
President Obama yesterday openly lying
about his record on fossil fuels for
example Barack Obama now takes credit
for everything from the economic
recovery the weakest economic recovery
in American history that he presided
over and growth really began in earnest
under a Republican Congress he he blames
they he takes credit for that and now he
takes credit for low oil prices this is
just unbelievable suddenly America's
like the biggest oil producer and the
biggest get that was me
people I just want you to pack so so
slow like you know sometimes you go to
Wall Street and folks would be grumbling
about anti-business I said have you
checked where your stocks were when I
came in office where they are now what
what are you talking what are you
complaining about just say thank you
please so he's the president for the oil
companies in Wall Street now which is
really interesting because that's not
how the oil companies felt when he takes
credit for us being the world's biggest
oil producer with the leading oil
producer this is honestly this is sort
of like the it's sort of like Ralph
Branca taking credit for Bobby
Thompson's home run I know it's an old
reference for people who aren't baseball
fans
but it's it's like a it's like a bad
pitcher saying that he takes credit for
the home run that was hit off of him
okay the oil companies had to work
around Barack Obama on routine basis he
was constantly attempting to prevent
people from drilling it was President
Obama who's trying to crack down on the
fracking industry that made oil and
natural gas that much cheaper and now
he's taking credit for all of this so
the reason I point this out is because
it is simply not rare in presidential
politics for presidents to take credit
for things they have nothing to do with
but that attitude does lead to bad
policy whether you're talking
Republicans or Democrats and I'm gonna
get to that bad policy in just a second
with regard to General Motors but first
let's talk about what you are going to
get your loved ones for this holiday you
never you know what does not go out of
style surprising a friend or loved one
with a dazzling bouquet from 1-800
flowers calm I have a habit that
whenever I go out of town i order my
wife flowers from 1-800 flowers dot-com
what's great about that is makes my life
easy I can just order the flowers it
takes me five seconds to show my wife
then I'm thinking about her she really
appreciates the flowers I even have my
assistant write a love note or just so I
don't have to do it just kidding I
actually write the love note myself I
know but it is very short that is true
just think how great you'll make them
deal with a surprise bouquet of vibrant
roses 1-800 flowers are perfect for any
occasion anniversaries birthdays even
for making your friend or loved ones day
just because and right now 1-800 flowers
has amazing deals on bouquets and
arrangements starting at just $29.99
$29.99 I'm telling you the flowers are
gorgeous I mean they really are great
and they say they last roses from 1-800
flowers are picked at their peak they're
shipped overnight to ensure freshness
and for amazement gorgeous bouquets
starting at $29.99 it's an amazing deal
the offer is not going to last long
right now go to 1-800 flowers dot-com /
Shapiro again 1-800 flowers calm /
appear oh and save you can get those
bouquets arrangements starting just 29
bucks 99 cents it's a great present
1-800 flowers calm / up hero when people
say that the ladies love the flowers it
is true 1-800 flowers calm / apparel go
check it out ok I want to talk about
General Motors and president Trump's war
with General Motors in just a second but
you're gonna have to go over to Daley
wire comm and check it out for $9.99 a
month you can get a subscription to
daily wire when you do you got the rest
of the show live the rest of Michael
Moses show live the rest of Andrew
clavin's show live I mean these are all
great shows except for Michael Knowles
you're gonna want to be part of them and
you get all sorts of great goodies like
you get to see all of our
answers when we do the Sunday special
like there's a final answer the final
answer we get from our guests on the
Sunday special you don't get that unless
you're a subscriber so for example this
week's Sunday special features my good
friend David Limbaugh who I've known for
17 years but only met in person
yesterday David is going to be on the
Sunday special talking about as I
mentioned yesterday our upcoming pre
Christmas series who can convert Ben
Shapiro here's a new book called Jesus
is risen we talk about religion and
politics and all the rest here's a
little bit of preview I'm David Limbaugh
I want to encourage you to tune in this
week to the Ben Shapiro show the Sunday
special he was gracious enough to
interview me and we talked about my book
jesus is risen we talk about Trump and
Christianity church and state
the founding fathers and whether they
were Christian I think we have a good
wholesome discussion at least been
contributed very well I was sitting here
listening so you can go check that out
this Sunday when you subscribe also
subscribe over at iTunes or YouTube
leave us a review and when you get the
annual subscription for $99 you get this
the very greatest and beverage vessels
now as I say everyone my family has been
ill I have not and I'm not going to
pretend that it's because of this
tumbler but let me just say that without
this tumbler I don't know what it would
have been do you I mean who knows could
have been different no lots of
circumstances in life and every every
point is an inflection point so who
knows if I had not taken a sip from this
perhaps right now I'd be definitely ill
I can't I can't give you any more of a
guarantee than that I'm sorry but you
can get all of that for 99 dollars a
year again we are the largest
fastest-growing conservative podcast in
the nation
[Music]
okay so speaking of fulmination
President Trump is very very upset at
General Motors General Motors
has just decided that they are going to
outsource a bunch of jobs they're going
to cut a bunch of factories in the
United States none of this is
particularly shocking but President
Trump is very very angry at it the
reason he's angry at it is because
General Motors basically signaled months
ago that the steel tariffs the president
Trump was now putting on we're going to
damage its business so at a rally in
Youngstown Ohio last year he talked
about how we weren't gonna lose any
automotive jobs Jim has estimated that
the tariffs that President Trump put on
steel and aluminum have cost the company
hundreds of millions of dollars they
said that this was not the sole reason
for the cuts Ford announced last month
that it would make an unspecified number
of cuts as part of a redesign of the
company they say that the tariffs have
cost the company 1 billion dollars so
far and Robert Scott who's a senior
economist of the Economic Policy
Institute left-leaning said despite GM's
assertions to the contrary the company
is likely to protect itself too against
a future economic downturn says they can
read the crystal ball they see what's
coming this is chickens coming home to
roost on the broader Trump economic
policies of course this is a leftist
saying so but this has got president
from very angry because President Trump
likes auto jobs
he likes manufacturing jobs and he's
upset with GM this has caused President
Trump to get very angry at GM and blast
them saying that they better put jobs
back in or gonna kill the subsidies to
GM so just to get this straight the US
government never should have been
subsidizing GM we should have allowed GM
to go bankrupt back in 2008 if we had
allowed GM go back Rab bankrupt back in
2008 it would've been scrapped and sold
off for parts or more likely the brand
would have been maintained and brought
up by other investors for pennies on the
dollar at which point they would have
created new efficiencies and new costs
of scale new efficiencies of scale they
would have made the company better and
stronger and then it would have been on
more competitive international footing
instead we subsidized it with hundreds
of millions of dollars from the United
States Treasury and when we did that we
took an ownership stake in GM and then
resold the ownership stake in geo and
all the rest when we did that we put
them basically on the government toll
and this caused President Trump to say
okay well if you ship jobs overseas then
we are going to remove your subsidies
which by the way will actually involve
GM losing more jobs so you taking more
money out of GM's pocket doesn't make
more likely to bring the jobs back it
makes them more likely to cut more jobs
here's President Trump however saying
that he wants to punish GM for making an
economically feasible decision thanks in
part to his tariffs the General Motors
you better get back in there soon that's
Ohio and you better get back in there
soon so we have a lot of pressure on
them you have senators you have a lot of
other people a lot of pressure
they say the Chevy Cruze is not selling
well I say well then get somebody get a
car that is selling well and put it back
in okay well thank you for that
information on running a car company
president Trump the Chevy Cruze isn't
selling well maybe we were out of bet
maybe we ought to use a different car
and put it back in that's what they're
doing but the Chevy Cruze is mainly
manufactured in the United States and a
lot of their other cars their SUVs are
manufactured overseas or at least in
part overseas also it's really silly to
talk about where these cars are
manufactured as though the Chevy Cruzes
manufactured 100% in America that's not
how any of this works
there are supply chains that extend all
across the world when you raise tariffs
on products and auto inputs it raises
the price it makes you less competitive
so how did President Trump respond to
all of this by more interference in the
economy this is why I don't like when
presidents take sole credit for economic
wins or economic losses as though they
are responsible for creating jobs Obama
was not responsible for creating jobs
private industry was responsible for
creating jobs you can create a business
climate that is friendlier for job
creation but you the President of the
United States are not responsible for
creating jobs because you do not have
the capacity to do anything other than
take money that does not belong to you
and spend it on people who are then
going to be in your political pocket so
what exactly does his president Trump
doing so he put in the steel tariffs
this damage to the car companies now in
response he wants to get more involved
in the economy he wants to go after GM
by removing their subsidies which we
should never have given them in the
first place and then he wants to raise
tariffs on car imports to create a
protectionist kind of Placid swimming
pool for GM he says the reason that the
small truck business in the u.s. is such
a go-to favorite is that for many years
tariffs of 25 percent have been put on
small trucks coming into our country it
is called the chicken tax if we did that
with cars coming in many more cars would
be built here and GM would not be
closing their plants in Ohio Michigan
and Maryland Get Smart Congress also the
countries the
send us cars have taken advantage of the
u.s. for decades the president has great
power on this issue because of the GM
event it is being studied now so now he
threatened so he did steel tariffs which
hurt the car industry now he says what
if I protect the car industry by putting
on tariffs well what will that affect
that will affect everyone who buys a car
in the United States will now be more
expensive to buy a car or a truck in the
United States which has downstream
economic effects on other businesses
because now you're not going to be able
to spend that dollar that you were going
to spend on something else on that thing
you're now going to have to spend it on
this car because President Trump decided
to raise the tariff rates this is the
thing about policies like tariffs that
have a small number of beneficiaries but
diffuse numbers of people who are hurt
right if it hurts me a hundred bucks
worth
but somebody gets to keep a job at GM
it's very obvious to the person who
keeps the job at GM that their job is
due to the tariff it's not clear to me
than my $100 increase in price outweighs
that person's job but what if it's
millions of people paying $100 extra hey
all of this is not economically
efficient it is simple redistribution of
love that's all that's happening here
this is not for national security
reasons President Trump has a deep and
abiding love for tariffs his abiding
love for tariffs is going to be
extraordinarily economically damaging he
has a very very strong economy the
economy was probably artificially
boosted last quarter because so many
companies in the United States decided
to import product now as opposed to
waiting for president Trump's tariffs to
kick in right now a lot of American
companies that are exporters are seeing
retaliatory tariffs from other countries
in particular the soybean industry in
the United States is about to collapse
entirely soybean exports which from the
United States mainly go to China have
decreased by 98% going into January
apparently is that good for the economy
you may say that we ought to fight China
that's fine but let's not pretend that
it's economically beneficial for us to
do so that's that's silly but President
Trump again when you think that the job
of the president is to run things to run
the economy to run things then you get
yourself into all sorts of hot water
here also all of this stuff is is simply
not feasible in the long run I'm gonna
explain why in a second all these
subsidies and tariffs and trying to
protect certain industries none of its
feasible in the long run now the reason
that none of this stuff is feasible in
the long run the reason that tariff
policy that protectionism that control
from the
top down whether it's by Trump or Obama
whether it's Obama on oil and gas order
this Trump on cars
the reason none of this is feasible in
the long run is that technological
advances outpace the capacity of
governments to control those
technological advances President Obama
tried to shut down oil drilling what did
that do it artificially raised the price
of oil by doing so it provided incentive
for businesses to create fracking those
businesses then lowered the price of gas
natural gas undercutting the coil of the
coal industry and also ensuring a cheap
supply of natural gas for the future
because President Obama was restricting
oil supply and the same thing is going
to happen in the car industry
uber CEO says and I think he's entirely
right about this then in ten years
nobody is going to own a car
here is what abruzzo Dera crusher Shashi
ASI pronounced said that in a decade
nobody's gonna own a car and I think
this is probably correct hopefully you
won't on a car you essentially come to
us and we will give you the choice of
whether you want to take regular uber
you want to pull with someone but we're
also gonna show you this is a bus stop
that's not to you and a bus is going to
be coming in six minutes from now you
can take the bus today or you can take
an electric bike or scooter today as
well we want to give you every single
choice okay so the car industry I
totally agree this by the way I think
the car industry in the United States is
going to completely collapse in a manner
of adding 10 years is too soon I think
within 20 years automated driving
combined with uber technology is going
to allow you to not own a car right
basically you're just gonna pull up an
app on your phone if we even have apps
on phones by then we're going to be able
to simply pull up an app on our phone
punch a button and then a car with the
requisite number of seats will arrive to
take you to your destination it won't be
worth a tonne a car you're just going to
buy a subscription from a company like
uber you're gonna pay a hundred bucks a
month to buy that subscription from uber
and you're gonna pay that $100 a month
instead of paying for an individual ride
and you can use as many cars as you want
and that's how the car industry is going
to work how exactly do you crack down on
that well people like tucker carlson
have said on the show actually that they
would prevent automatic driving from
happening to protect jobs but you know
what's gonna happen then all is gonna
happen then is other economies are gonna
take advantage of those technologies and
those other economies are gonna grow
faster than the united states economy
you want to know why america's
is the dominant world economy because it
does not prevent innovation because it
does not freeze the economy and attempt
to redistribution it does not see
innovation as a threat it sees it as a
benefit and for all those people who
think oh well we're gonna kill too many
jobs with all this stuff we have
literally said this about every
technological advance of the last 200
years for 200 years people have been
doomed saying that every technological
advance was going to end with a massive
unemployment it has not happened there
are people who will be unemployed for a
short period of time and then they'll
get jobs in other industries there will
be people who are retrained for other
jobs should we ease their way sure
that's what social fabric is for that's
where social institutions come in but
this idea that from the top down you're
simply going to redistribute jobs to
particular areas you need to win in a
presidential election this says that the
federal government is simply too
powerful
this says the federal government is
involved in crap that it should not be
involved in in the first place and that
is true whether you're talking about oil
drilling under Barack Obama or whether
you're talking about car industry stuff
under under Donald Trump this is not the
business of the federal government this
is not the business of the President of
the United States absent a national
security need now meanwhile I will say
that president Trump's continued
popularity has very little to do I think
there's been an attempt to link his
popularity among Republicans with GM
blue-collar Rust Belt kind of stuff I
don't think that's reality I think that
President Trump remains popular because
he has a gut level his gut is right on
this he has a gut level patriotism for
the United States unfortunately his gut
level patriotism for the United States
is not being reflected by Millennials
there's a new study out that shows that
Millennials half of them think that
America isn't great and think that
Barack Obama was more important than
George Washington a new poll conducted
by the foundation for Liberty and
American greatness found that a huge
percentage of younger Americans are
expressing their disdain for American
ideals almost half believe America isn't
great roughly 20% think the American
flag is a sign of intolerance and hatred
29% were okay with burning the American
flag we have it some serious crises of
American conscience that are cropping up
with younger Americans and in the near
future that's why when President Trump
says he's better than Ronald Reagan if
he wants to be better than Ronald Reagan
it can't just be that he's cutting
regulation it has to be that he's making
an affirmative case for America as a
great free country and why you should
join that adventure rather than sitting
on the sidelines screaming about how
Merrick
is terrible otherwise we will see the
end of America no matter how good the
economy is people are driven by ideas
people are driven by passion people are
not necessarily driven simply by the
pocketbook and that is particularly true
when you're talking about young people
who mainly are living off mommy and
daddy's pocketbook okay time for some
things I like and then some things that
I hate so things that I like today this
is the second book by Jesse Norman I've
recommended in in a couple of months I
recommended his biography of Adam Smith
his first biography was of Edmund Burke
one of the first real conservatives
Edmund Burke's conservatism was of a
brand that suggested that basically
Western civilization had been the
product of a fabric created over
thousands of years and hundreds of
generations and that that fabric had to
be preserved and that if we were going
to change the fabric then we had best
considered what it was we're removing
before replacing it now this is why
Edmund Burke was not a fan of the French
Revolution but he was a fan of the
American Revolution which he saw as
Americans simply seeking to defend their
rights as Englishmen and he saw the
French Revolution as people who were
seeking to overthrow the fundamental
institutions of society the book is
really good by Jesse Norman Edmund Burke
the first conservative this is not the
only biography of Edmund Burke that's
good Russell Kirk has one that's quite
good if you are actually interested in
conservatism the history of conservative
thought and not merely tax rates then
it's incumbent on you to read some
Edmund Burke who really is terrific and
and an amazing writer by the way very
readable and I even though he was
writing in the late 18th century so go
check that out right now okay other
things that I like today well I have to
admit that I do actually like this story
from a sci-fi writer who says that the
orcs from Lord of the Rings are racist I
am not kidding science fiction author
Andrew Duncan has a message for JRR
Tolkien fans
he says Tolkien discriminated against
orcs and the Lord of the Rings books
promote racism duncan was discussing
Lord of the Rings as part of a wider
discussion on fantasy he says it's hard
to miss the repeated notion in Tolkien
that some races are just worse than
others or that some people are just
worse than others and this seems to me
in the long term if you embrace this too
much
it has dire consequences for yourself
and for society uh-huh
a couple of things one Lord of the Rings
is written with the Nazis in mind are
some people worse than others yes yes
they are you know how you could tell
sometimes when they wear a swastika on
their arm that's a pretty good indicator
that's not a good person so this is
insane but but again for folks on the
Left who believe that that everybody is
of equal moral value and their every
choice is of equal moral value this is
this is silliness also the idea that
it's it's discriminatory because it
leads to the idea that biologically
there are no good orcs it's a fantasy
book you dope and not only is it a
fantasy book nowhere in that book is
there a suggestion that hobbits
themselves are genetically good right I
mean not to not spoiler alert from 80
years ago but Smeagol was once a hobbit
right so the fact is that Smeagol turned
bad he turned into Smeagol so it this
whole thing is just solely but you know
silliness in the indie woke sci-fi
community has become a thing which is
why I think sci-fi literature is getting
worse and worse he says we should allow
the orcs to explain themselves uh-huh so
that that's yeah they mainly do it seems
like they want to eat people that's
that's their that's their thing okay
time for a couple of things that I hate
okay so things that I hate there are all
these stories that often go viral and
this is a and it's really absurd why
these things go viral here is one
example and there's a teen who graduated
from a Catholic High School and when he
spoke at this Catholic High School he
was met for with a standing ovation why
because he came out as gay in front of
the high school and here is what he had
to say
the world is like you
I decided that it was finally time to
tell someone the truth it wasn't easy
but I told my mom that I don't mind a
guy when I said it I felt this energy
passed through me and I felt that was
the first time I'd really been proud of
who I was everybody is wow it's so brave
it's so wonderful first of all bravery
requires risk I'm not sure what the risk
is here I mean this is a guy who's now
being featured on the news for saying
he's of a particular sexual orientation
in front of a crowd second you know I
went to an Orthodox Church High School
the standard at the Orthodox Jewish High
School there were standards on a lot of
things on Sabbath observance on kosher
observance and YES on sexual
proclivities and sexual practices to go
to to go into a place where everyone
knows the standard up front and to
enroll in that place with the agreement
that you're going to abide by those
rules and then to get up and then say
that the rules are bad as you graduate
is not really an act of respect it is
not really an act even of self-respect
it is an act of rebellion against the
school that you basically lied to if you
want to come out come out do whatever
you want man it's a free society that I
really don't care but if you're going to
go to take my example a Jewish day
school and then at your graduation
you're going to announce you know what I
hate Sabbath Sabbath is not for me
Sabbath is dumb and I think this whole
thing has been a sham is that bravery or
is it just you being kind of a jerk
now I'm not saying that being gay is him
being a jerk obviously not he as I just
said if he wants to come out let him
come out but you take the advantage of a
Catholic school graduation and then to
say at the Catholic school graduation by
the way your entire moral standard with
regard to sexuality is wrong and you
should change it because I'm gay is
really not an act of humility or decency
it's really an act of self
aggrandizement that I don't think is
really worthy of celebration again for
the 1,000 time in the segment do
whatever you want but if the idea here
is that you're doing something grand and
good by challenging the status quo at a
school that you apparently accepted the
moral standards of when you were going
there seems to me a slap in the face to
the religious upbringing from once you
came and the school to which you go you
want to leave the school and then rip
the school for its policies fine
you want to take advantage of their
platform to talk about how you hate
everything they stand for on this
particular issue because it makes you
feel good in front of 1,500 people not
cool now if you want and here's the
other thing if the school approve the
speech if the school is cool with it
then still not sure how it's brave
because at that point the school
approves of it so either this is an act
of self aggrandizement or it's not a lot
of bravery bravery would be if you want
to come out and then challenge bad
policy right and you want to challenge a
bad policy but if you want to go to a
religious school that you went to and
then then rip the school I just I think
that that's I think it's an active of
true arrogance in a certain respect and
again I'm I don't think this kid thinks
of it like that and I don't blame him
but I don't think the media have to
celebrate this sort of stuff either okay
other things that I hate today so
there's this story about this American
Christian missionary who was killed when
he tried to contact a hostile
hunter-gatherer tribe on an isolated
island in the Indian Ocean
so some see John Chow is a symbol of
Western arrogance is according to the
Washington Post a reckless evangelist
who attempted to supplant a culture
thousands of years old when he broke
Indian law and set forth set foot on the
North Sentinel island some Christians
seem as a martyr if perhaps misguided
one who recognized no exceptions to the
IVA evangelist mission when he tried to
take the Bible to a people known to kill
Outsiders on site but only one person
gleaned from chess laying a model for
national immigration policy that there's
a piece in Australia about how the
natives had a great immigration policy
but in any case the here here's where I
think all of this goes wrong so I want
to talk about the perspective that the
tribe was okay killing this guy why just
why like I don't understand talk about
the soft bigotry of low expectations so
if you come to my house with a book in a
western civilized society missionaries
come to my house all the time because
people knock on your door and they want
to talk about the Book of Mormon right
they want to talk about they want to
talk about the Latter day Saints or they
want to talk about seventh-day Adventism
or something
let's say they did that I went into my
gun safe I took out my pistol and I shot
them to death on my doorstep this would
make me a fairly crappy human being and
when I say fairly crappy I mean an
irredeemably crappy human being right if
I just if somebody
to me and said I'd like to talk to you
about Jesus like I did my Sunday
conversation with David Limbaugh and he
said I'd like to talk to you bout my
book jesus is risen and I took this
tumbler and beat him to death with it
this would make me a very very bad
person it would make me guilty of murder
I would probably be executed if I were
not in to the state of California in the
state of California if you kill a
Christian then basically they they
actually make you a saint I think in the
state of California but and but if we
were in a normal state then then this
would make me a bad person I don't
understand that because why if you live
in a primitive tribe it's okay to kill
somebody who shows up on your Island
with a book why is it because they're
more innocent this noble savage ratina
well they're they're just noble well not
really when you kill somebody showing up
again if you're a Christian missionary
showing up there with a gun to try and
convert people at sword point that's one
thing if you're somebody who's showing
up to talk to somebody about God and the
afterlife I don't understand why we
should celebrate a pagan tribe for doing
that when we would rightly in Western
civilization excoriate anybody who did
something similar to anyone of any
particular religious sect primitivism is
still primitive even when practiced by
primitive people okay and these are and
when I say primitive that's not meant as
an insult these are people who are
literal hunter-gatherers who live in
like loincloth this is like an actual
description and they're not
sophisticates they're not cultural
sophisticates okay they're not building
cars
she has no plants on this island so it's
I don't understand why it is that we in
the West are so sanguine about the the
evil activities and it is evil to murder
people okay this shouldn't be
controversial
the evil activities of people who are
not from Western societies really like I
would expect better behavior from my
four and a half year old okay my two and
a half year old not because he's a
monster in any case well is it let's
talk about a Federalist Papers so we're
all the way up to Federalist 51 one of
my favorite Federalist Papers well I
really like Federalist 51 one of the
more famous Federalist Papers and one of
the most oft quoted for a reason nude by
James Madison it's about checks and
balances why we need checks and balances
in the government and how to achieve
that so there are several fundamental
principles he talks about in Federalist
51 he says first every department must
be separate and have little impact on
appointment to other branches so you
can't have members of the executive
branch appointing members of the
legislative branch or basically the
legislative branch would be in control
of the executive branch you can't have
members of the legislative branch at
point members of the executive branch or
the executive branch will be in the
control
the legislative branch this is one of
the reasons why the idea of bureaucratic
government is such a problem because
bureaucratic government you basically
have bureaucracies that are created by
the executive branch and are given
tremendous leeway by the legislature to
create regulations that belong inside
the legislature the founders never would
have thought that there should be such a
thing as a 2 million person executive
branch it's insane ok two branches must
be able to avoid encroachments by other
branches so you want the branches to
fight with each other and defend their
own priorities and power from one
another so Madison says this and this is
again one the most off cited parts of
the Federalist Papers for reason his
ambition must be made to counteract
ambition the interest of the man must be
connected with the constitutional rights
of the place it may be a reflection on
human nature that such devices should be
necessary to control the abuses of
government but what is government itself
but the greatest of all reflections on
human nature if men were angels this is
the most important single line in the
Federalist Papers right here if men were
angels no government would be necessary
if angels were to govern men neither
external nor internal controls on the
government would be necessary in framing
and government which is which is to be
administered by men over men the great
difficulty lies in this you must first
enable the government to control the
governed in the next place oblige it to
control itself a dependence on the
people is no doubt the primary control
on the government but experience has
taught mankind the necessity of
auxiliary precautions so he's saying is
people aren't angels people aren't
Devils if people were Devils no
government could control them if people
were angels you wouldn't need a
government to control them so what you
need is a government that can protect
people from the predations of others and
at the same time is capable of stopping
its own predations how do you do that
you do that by creating a multiplicity
of interest in pitting them against one
another so only an overwhelming
consensus on an issue allows anything to
get done this is to protect the rights
of minorities so he says quote it is of
great importance in a republic not only
to guard the society against the
oppression of its rulers but to guard
one part of the society against the
injustice of the other part different
interests necessarily exist in different
classes of citizens if a majority be
united by a common interest the rights
of the minority will be insecure
therefore what you really need he says
is that the society itself will be
broken into so many parts interest in
classes of citizens that the rights of
individuals or of the minority will be
in little danger from interested
combinations of the majora
it is no less certain than it is
important notwithstanding the contrary
opinions which have been entertained
that the larger of the society provided
it lie within a practical sphere the
more duly capable it will be of
self-government and happily for the
Republican cause the practicable sphere
may be carried to a very great extent by
a judicious modification and mixture of
the federal principle so we want the
states to check the federal government
we want the legislature to have two
branches that will have two chambers
that will check each other we want the
legislature to check the executive the
executive to check the judicial the
judicial to check both we want all of
these things to happen right and we want
that because we don't actually want lots
of things to get done see this is the
great lie about they get from every
president why can't we get more done
politics is broken why can't we get more
done we don't want things to get done
getting things done is a threat to your
freedom the only way things should get
done is if we were to have in enormous
if we were to have an enormous consensus
on an issue an overwhelming consensus on
an issue if we were to have that
overwhelming consensus on an issue then
we got things done you make a
constitutional mement you pass a piece
of legislation but if not then we should
be very wary of doing things with the
power of the Ring right there the power
of government is the power of the one
ring better that it should be wielded by
no one then then it should be wielded by
one person who gets things done so I
don't like pragmatism politically and
this is why I'm not in favor of people
who think we should just run roughshod
and break all the things in order to get
done what I want to get done because
guess what that sword can be turned
against you tomorrow
already we'll be back here tomorrow with
all of the latest i'm ben shapiro this
is the ben shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover
and our technical producer is Austin
Stephens edited by Alex and Garo Audio
is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and makeup
is by Jesuit Vera the Ben Shapiro show
is a daily wire for word publishing
production copyright Ford publishing